many of us remember in 2012 after the
Sandy Hook elementary school shooting
when a number of right-wing conspiracy
theorists including Alex Jones suggested
that the shooting was a so-called false
flag attack coordinated by the Obama
administration to create anti-gun
sentiment as a pretext to putting more
gun laws in place and taking away
people's guns now most of us were aware
at the time of the absurdity of the idea
now we're even more aware of the
absurdity given that guns weren't taken
from people under Obama it actually saw
record gun purchases many people said
the same thing about 9/11 that the Bush
administration was either directly
responsible for the attack so that
they'd have public support for deploying
troops in the Middle East or at minimum
allowed the 9/11 attacks to happen I
think that those conspiracy theories are
nonsense but there are people who will
sometimes often or always say that
tragedies like those are staged by the
government to achieve certain political
goals and I've been thinking about this
over the last week in the context of the
Trump administration if the United
States government did that type of thing
create false flag attacks in that way
there would be no better time to do it
than right now due to the acute scandal
after scandal situation that Donald
Trump finds himself in I mean on the
brink of major revelations related to
the validity of his presidency in the
context of Russia and not only that the
constant scandals have put Donald Trump
at the lowest approval rating of any
other president at the same point in
their presidency roughly 60 I think as
of today 64 days in and terrorist
attacks attacks by other countries
threats of attacks these do tend to
create a spike in the sitting
president's approval rating it improves
their public image because people become
more so-called patriotic they set aside
political differences on domestic issues
they rally around the president and I'm
not speculating about that that happens
take a look at a few examples here are
some events in history where the u.s.
was attacked there Americans were in
danger and the resulting approval
ratings spike of the president in power
Frank
Delano Roosevelt gained 12 approval
points when Pearl Harbor happened
Kennedy gained 13 approval points when
the Cuban Missile Crisis took place
Jimmy Carter gained 26 approval ratings
points during the Iran hostage crisis
and George W Bush as many of us remember
during September 11th gained 35 points
in his presidential approval donald
trump has attempted to use this
mechanism not with terrorist attacks but
with other ideas right with no evidence
he accused President Obama of
wiretapping trump tower during the
election I genuinely don't know which
scandal that was meant to distract from
whether it was the Russia stuff or
pre-empting the disastrous release of
the American healthcare act who knows
and again to be super clear Pat I'm not
saying that I think any particular
incident was a false flag attack and I
don't think 9/11 was a false flag I
don't think Sandy Hook was a false flag
I've debunked those conspiracy theories
and I'm not saying I want any sort of
attack to occur what I'm saying is that
if you follow the logic of right-wing
conspiracy theorists who often say that
major acts of violence are manufactured
by the government to manipulate the
public wouldn't right now be the perfect
time for the Trump administration or
even just someone who supports Trump to
cause or allow something like that to
happen in order to raise Donald Trump's
disastrous approval rating I just think
that we live in a day and age where that
really wouldn't be possible because
there would be so many people who would
have to be part of this and just keep
secret over the years and there would be
so many things that could potentially be
leaked and get out to the public
especially when it comes to the Trump
administration because they are so
incompetent that they couldn't even hide
the fact that the president was playing
golf in mar-a-lago I don't disagree with
you about the difficulty of the
logistics but do you recognize that this
would create a diversion from most of
the scandals and mishaps it would give
the American people some kind of common
enemy so that they would focus less on
what Donald Trump is doing maybe even
give the president in the federal
government a pretext to use power to
fight back against whatever supposedly
attacked us or did bad things I mean the
the the oftentimes the conspiracy
theorists talk about motive
there's motive right now the logic makes
total sense absolutely I don't think
anyone can argue with that look at those
spikes and presidential approval ratings
yeah I mean after 9/11 george w bush's
approval went up to like 90% yeah it was
super super high this is not a
prediction this is not a wish this is
the reality of the situation that Trump
finds himself in today shockingly just
two months into his presidency send me
your thoughts about this I'm curious to
hear from the audience about this one